six groupes porcinet et coco lapin
bourriquet bourriquet winnie l'ourson
l'ours est si populaire qu'il a sa
propre journée internationale c'est le
18 janvier c'est vêtue que winnie doit
son prénom à la capitale du manitoba
winnipeg
tout commence avec cet homme ah oui
cobourne un anglais était bien uni pegg
et vétérinaire dans l'armée canadienne
avec la grande guerre en 1914
ah oui doit quitter winnipeg accompagné
de son régiment durant le voyage en
train il débarque à white river soit
c'est dans le nord ouest de l'ontario
il entend parler de la prise d'un
chasseur le nom sonne ah oui décide de
l'acheter pour 20 dollars si la surnomme
winnie d'après la ville où ils venaient
de s'établir winnipeg
l'animal devient une mascotte auprès des
hommes de la 2e brigade canadienne
d'infanterie il s'en occupe lors de leur
séjour à valcartier au québec
l'ours va même les accompagner jusqu en
angleterre où elle divertit les troupes
campé sur la plaine de salisbury
c'est là que les soldats se prépare est
au combat ah oui doit partir au front
pour garantir la sécurité de l'ours il
en fait cadeau au zoo de londres elle
devient l'attraction de l'endroit parmi
les admirateurs de winnie se trouve le
fils de l'auteur prolifique et et 1000
da
c'est d'ailleurs le lien entre eux et
aubigny et son fils qui les inspirent a
créé le personnage de winnie l'ourson
l'histoire de winnie the pooh et publié
pour la première fois le 14 octobre 1926
depuis la série de livres sur winnie
l'ourson de monsieur 1006 produits à
plus de 50 millions d'exemplaires bruni
de poids ont aussi été traduit en plus
de 50 langues incluant le catalan le
thaï et de latin et quant à winnie
l'ourson la vraie elle est morte au zoo
de londres à l'âge de 20 ans
[Musique]
encore aujourd'hui elle occupe une place
toute spéciale dans le coeur des
winnipeg oies à winnipeg le parc
assiniboine abrite une galerie dédiée
aux contes et à winnie l'ourson
c'est là que l'on peut trouver une
peinture faite par le premier ministre
at her de l'aciérie willy de poule et
est chez prudent elle représente winnie
l'ourson avec un pot de miel bio it
tu peux aussi éprouver une statue de
bronze du lieutenant harry et de winnie
immortalisant le lien entre cette tour
sonne bien spéciale et winnipeg
[Musique]